hello everyone welcome back to the
channel for a texas chainsaw interview
with one of my favorites in the business
it's elsie fisher i'm so happy to see
you oh man i mean so good to be here
just spanking around my headphones i'm
especially excited to talk to you right
now because i love horror but also i
know even beyond texas chainsaw you're
doing a whole lot of horror lately so
is there anything that jump-started the
the interest in or the draw to the genre
for you
yeah well i mean i i don't know if many
people agree with me but i personally
think uh my film eighth grade is a
horror movie because real life eighth
grade was you know felt like being a
horror uh protagonist
um but you know i i pretty much directly
after that i also um i did castle rock
which was a tv show on hulu
um
and that was stephen king and that was
that was really cool i don't know just
been riding with it
good stuff i'm mighty excited for your
grady hendrix movie
yes uh that was such a delight to film
and um i am a big fan of uh the book my
best friend's exorcism so that should be
fun
i'm psyched for that book adaptation and
i need someone to adapt horror story
have you ever read that one
i haven't read it but i really want to
because i also think ikea is very scary
so
it's very visceral you know
yes absolutely i can understand that so
you do a bunch of horror but what was it
about texas chainsaw in particular that
made you say like this feels like the
right movie for me to do right now where
like you could learn something new
within the horror genre from it
i mean i i think for me i hadn't i
hadn't done a slasher before so it was
it was definitely different in that
regard which was a lot of fun um and a
lot of blood
um
yeah but i don't know i mean it's also
it's um it's a very prominent franchise
which was daunting in a lot of ways but
also um you know it was a fun challenge
to take hold of and i'd i'd seen the
original and i'd loved it a lot um and
been super traumatized by it so it's fun
to hop back in i feel like this is an
unfair question to ask but do you have a
favorite iconic slasher
i i mean i really i do i love texas
chainsaw um i do love scream a lot too
uh which is also getting its own little
iteration this year which i think is so
much fun that like i've never heard of
it i have no clue what franchise you're
talking yeah exactly
um it's so fun though i i like the
slashers that mix you know uh comedy and
horror elements so both of them
i always play a little fun slasher
survival game on one of my other shows
so i'll kind of post a pose a broad
question to you
if you were like real you we're in a
horror movie what what horror movie
cliche would you be how would you best
serve the group to give them a fighting
chance to survive the slasher
oh that's a great question honestly um
i don't know i mean
i think my first instinct is probably
like you know the um
you know whatever whatever the nerdy
character is
that probably that one
um if i was being generous with myself
i'd say maybe like
the leader who like makes it a good part
of the way and then sacrifices himself
at the end
um
yeah or i'd just be killed first there's
a lot of options to play with
i'm a multi-faceted person so
i feel like i believe in your first
answer the most because randy and
screams speak to me like i feel like i
would be randy and mindy in the new
movie
yeah yeah yeah i mean i think they're
they're very um relatable iconic
characters so
i'm you know i'm flattered
all right let's talk a little bit about
lyla now so
she's got an especially powerful
backstory that weaves into the plot of
the movie quite a bit so what kind of
extra prep work do you have to do to
just you know really understand what
she's going through and where her head
is at as she makes decisions while
trying to survive leatherface
yeah of course i mean yeah her her whole
backstory was really important for me to
kind of um get right and bring as much
nuance as i could to it
because you know i mean of course this
is a genre film so like that's not
necessarily the focus but i think um you
know being the survivor of a school
shooting that's like a very visceral or
that you know that's um unfortunately
quite common in my age group so
um
i don't know i i did a lot of research
uh
just kind of
what people were like and it was just
big for me even like it was big for me
for her to not be defined by her trauma
and still be allowed to be a little like
[ __ ] teenager especially to her
sister um because then you know
it just brings it full circle and then
you're also still like rooting for her
to maybe not die i hope
oh i was very caught up in the sister
element of it all like i keep thinking
about how i was rooting for both of them
to not die but i also kept catching
myself feeling concerned for like them
not dying not for them individually but
for each other so i feel like that's a
sign that that element of the movie is
very strong
yes we did it we did it
i love the two of you together
oh i it was a lot of fun to make sarah
is really fun and um
you know it's it's a really fun uh
dynamic between the two of them
let's talk a little bit about sarah as a
scene part i love talking about scene
partners in general because i don't
think we do that nearly enough so what
is something about what she did for you
on set as a scene partner that you
really appreciated and maybe brought
something out of your own character that
you wouldn't have been able to access
without her yeah um i mean yeah she was
really great i think she was very like
present um which
you know uh not like every actor even
knows how to be and that's like a that's
um i don't know that's a big thing for
me so she was always present always open
to
um collaboration
which is also very important for a scene
partner but um
yeah and it's um
i don't know i mean she also she kept
the environment very light
which ended up being very important for
shooting something that has uh such a
dark tone as this one like we had a lot
of late nights where it was just the two
of us and we do a lot of just
you know kind of going crazy with each
other um keeping each other
it's as sane as we could with like humor
so that's great i'm happy to hear you
had that outlet so so you said humor but
what else was kind of like the go-to in
between takes to make sure that like
you're not like fully consumed by the
story and the darkness of it
um i mean i think there were a lot of
running jokes that we kind of had i
don't remember all of them but um
especially when
we had gone back to do some of the
reshoots because i think we we reached
out the ending um originally it was a
little bit different and i love what we
ended up doing but anyways there's like
a a lot more rain in the stuff we did
and we had gone back in the winter to
shoot it and so we were just like
sopping wet in the winter freezing and
after the takes we just run into the
tent and we'd be like ah you know what
this movie is this movie is like
kind of like ratatouille mixed with like
you know um
manchester by this e and we just do that
with the most random movies we could
think of and i think they were all
pretty accurate uh descriptions of texas
chainsaw so i never would have come up
with that on my own but i'm glad you're
sharing you're opening my mind right now
all right let's talk a little bit about
the gore i love gore i think it's art
from top to bottom
what is a lesson learned about working
on a slasher movie with heavy blood
heavy gore heavy special effects makeup
that you are going to put in your back
pocket and take with you to a future
slasher film i alright well
i might need a break from horror for a
bit this is intense but
um
i think
have lots of lots of makeup wipes cause
that blood will stain um and it'll like
even even just on the the car ride home
from after you know the 12 14 16 hour
days but even in the van ride home you
can just feel it seeping into your skin
so
lots of makeup wipes um
and
uh you know i don't know but try to have
fun with it i i felt like a kid with
finger paints half the time so it was it
was a lot of fun i appreciate that
mentality i have to ask you about the
bus scene was that the most challenging
i mean you just described a very
challenging seeming set
but was that particular one more
challenging than any of the others
the well the nice part was
even though it's quite intense the
amount of time that um
like me and sarah were on the bus was
was relatively short
um
and i think i think that sequence also
as as prominent as it is it goes by
quite quickly it you know it's probably
not much longer than five minutes i
think
um five ten minutes but like yeah so we
weren't in there uh very often but it
was very crazy and there were a lot of
people and a lot of um
yeah a lot of very talented extras we
had the hardest part about the bus scene
for me though
is
right in the middle of it i get pushed
down into that pile of blood
um and that was kind of cool on the day
because like they had the actual pile on
the ground and like
but then from that point on in the movie
i'm covered in blood on my entire body
so every day um that took place after
then they would get they cut up this
trash bag so it was flat they had a like
a milk jug full of blood and then like
they're like all right get on the ground
kid lie down
um
and it you know but this is this is the
price i paid i have the the nine to five
i have so
i mean i'm obsessed with all that stuff
it sounds kind of fun to me
all right before i have to let you go
i'm putting up the spoiler warning
because i wanted to ask you not just one
now but now i have two questions about
the ending
first do you have any hope for lila at
the end of the movie or do you think she
is she's kind of like doomed at this
point to follow sally's path now
yeah i mean i i think it's i mean
the ending is quite abrupt um in that
way
i think
it's kind of open where it could really
go either way and it just depends on
what what kind of tone you're going for
i hope she's fine i hope she like gets
into therapy
and like just has like you know really
important conversations and talks about
this awful thing not even in any sort of
supernatural scope um and then she
starts like doing really well in life
and then um
leatherface like goes to the city and
kills her
oh god that got really dark okay
i mean i think it's
it's the karmic destiny of final girls
you know i guess so i mean leatherface
in the city sounds kind of interesting
i'm a big fan of jason takes manhattan
so
why not yeah let's do it so now i have
to follow up about the alternate ending
you filmed can you tell us what that was
and i'm just i'm i'm curious did melody
survive in the other version
the um
no it was it was more it was more my
final encounter with leatherface um i
think it was a lot just shorter
and we ended up adding um
the very cool
uh um pool sequence and all of that um
which by the way that that shot of me
going through the theater with the gun
is like i think i think that turned out
so well and that was crazy intense to
shoot because um i was holding like an
actual not loaded but an actual shotgun
um and that thing is like 35 pounds it
was heavy so
pretty badass sequence right there
yeah
i mean i gotta let you go you got more
texas chainsaws celebrating to do
to take care of yourself have a rest but
then hurry up and make more horror
movies this is
fun all right well thank you very much
this has been lovely